Better yet, we can chain together all the matrices that effect an object and
store what 3JS calls a world matrix. Say we have a hubcap that's part of a
wheel, that's part of a car. Each of these objects has its own concatinated
matrix of transforms. If a program wants to display the hubcap on the screen, we
need to multiply the hubcap's vertices by these three matrices in turn. Instead
of doing three matrix multiplies, we can concatenate the three matrices to form
a single world matrix and store that separately for the hubcap. This matrix is
the world matrix, or it's sometimes called the model matrix. Whatever you call
it, a single matrix multiply is then all that is needed to transform a vertex
from its model space to world space directly.